I'm really glad I got in that car with
you
all cameras
I'm axon transformers partnership
started 10 years ago with the first
transformers and the partnership has
gotten more traction throughout each one
IMAX gives me the tools to give you the
best cinema experience in the world
transformers has been a giant part of
our brand it helped build IMAX
Michael's pushed us to be more nimble
therefore smaller but not to compromise
resolution he's pushed us for the 3d to
be more seamless he's constantly trying
to surge the filmmaking experience
giving media here
on this movie transformers last night we
are shooting with IMAX 3d and the
results are phenomenal Michael is the
very first filmmaker to take two of
these cameras and configure them on a 3d
rig and shoot in 3d in real time and
that's not trivial the resolution the
detail the clarity it really is
mind-boggling we are using all the IMAX
technology to give you the best
experience you will see this year
I was looking for a dog and some decided
to take her on by which time Michael Bay
had shown interest in her action I said
first of all we'd give her part